quando quando ho deciso di fare il
medico e quindi mi sono iscritto a
medicina
la mia questa mia decisione era dettata
dal pd in maniera molto forte da una
figura che dalla figura del nostro
medico di famiglia che veniva a casa da
noi quando stavamo male visitava
mediterranea sorelle e poi si tratteneva
a chiacchierare amabilmente con i miei
genitori
altri tempi probabilmente anzi
sicuramente altre figure nel corso per
occhi dei miei studi mi sono poi
ritrovato a vedere pazienti con leucemia
pazienti col cancro e quindi sono
scivolato che diverso un'idea diversa
della medicina un'idea diversa nella
quale mi piaceva personalmente l'idea di
poter dare un contributo senza nulla
togliere al medico di famiglia di allora
e di oggi ovviamente ma un'idea diversa
di medicina che voleva cercare di fare
qualcosa in più
la vita poi è come sapete un po buffa
ball tech di una una lettera può
cambiarci la vita
questa è una lettera che io ho ricevuto
nel 1984 vedete scritte ancora con la
macchina da scrivere in cui
l'associazione italiana per la ricerca
sul cancro mi comunicava di aver vinto
una borsa di studio per l'estero
era una borsa di studio per un periodo
di tempo molto limitato o limitato che
io ho utilizzato per andati a lavorare a
new york
ansa galdino di new york in un centro di
immunologia dove nell 84 si iniziavano a
fare che di le prime esperienze di
immuno terapia dei tumori
poi un po come capita nella vita di
tutti quanti ci sono rimasto a 6 anni e
quindi a un certo punto ha 29 anni
trent'anni mi sono ritrovato un po
davanti al bivio resto ritorno ho deciso
di ritornare in qualche maniera
accettando un po una scommessa con me
stesso di voler provare a mettere in
piedi un progetto in italia che
coinvolgesse persone di alto livello
nell'ambito dell'immunoterapia dei
tumori
direi che questa scommessa almeno questa
scommessa è stata vinta perché oggi a
siena che abbiamo un centro di in cui
lavorano oltre 50 persone
molti di loro ricercatori attivi
nell'ambito che di le l'imu la terapia
dei tumori
ma cos'è l'immunoterapia del cancro è
sostanzialmente un part in cambio di
paradigma assoluto rispetto a ciò che
noi abbiamo utilizzato nell'ultimo
secolo direi per trattare che di tumori
umani questa è una vecchissima
diapositiva che io ormai uso da
probabilmente 30 anni che in qualche
maniera identifica anche in sequenza
temporale le strategie che noi abbiamo
che di avuto e abbiamo e in qualche
maniera avremo a disposizione per
trattare i tumori fino alla fine
dell'ottocento
c'era solo la chirurgia molte volte una
chirurgia devastante inutile perché non
aveva la possibilità di portare a casa
risultati importanti
poi agli inizi del novecento abbiamo
cominciato che di ad avere a
disposizione anche la radioterapia che
ha dato certamente un contributo e
continua a darlo al trattamento dei
tumori umani a questa poi negli anni 60
ha fatto seguito pd la chemioterapia che
è stata vista negli anni sessanta come
la strategia che avrebbe definitivamente
combattuto che di in maniera definitiva
i tumori umani però già negli ultimi
trent'anni di lei 40 anni c'era un
gruppo sparuto di oncologi che in giro
per il mondo
riteneva che questo non fosse
sufficiente e soprattutto che li teneva
nella quarta sfera credete colorata in
giallo che si potessero utilizzare le
nostre difese immunitarie per combattere
il cancro era se volete un gruppo di
visionari che si ritrovava in tutti i
convegni internazionali
alla fine del convegno nella sala più
lontana quella più sperduta ci si
parlava anche un po addosso ma che aveva
le basi razionali per continuare a
pensare in maniera molto pervicaci che
fosse possibile utilizzare il nostro
sistema immunitario cioè quello che noi
abbiamo all'interno del nostro organismo
tutti noi e che ci permette di
sopravvivere nell'ambiente esterno
quotidianamente per combattere il cancro
questa diapositiva io l'ho utilizzata
tantissime volte per dire poi c'è
l'immunoterapia che è una strategia
promettente bene non è più così non è
più così perché l'immunoterapia è
l'acqua sta strategia oggi che abbiamo a
disposizione per combattere il cancro e
quelli per sradicarlo quindi
dall'interno utilizzando il nostro
stesso organismo che vedete è in grado
nel corso della nostra vita della vita
di tutti noi di tenere sotto controllo e
distruggere delle cellule che decidono
diventare immortali quindi delle cellule
tumorali questo accade in alcune
occasioni però queste cellule diventano
talmente e capaci di sopravvivere che
sfuggono a questo controllo e quindi
abbiamo le evidenze clinica che li del
cancro sfuggire al controllo significa
che le nostre difese immunitarie non
sono più efficaci sono stanze messe
fuori gioco con l'immunoterapia noi cosa
facciamo
cambiamo completamente che il paradigma
non utilizziamo più qualsivoglia delle
tre strategie che abbiamo utilizzato
negli ultimi cent'anni bensì utilizziamo
dei farmaci che sono dei veri e propri
farmaci per potenziare le difese
immunitarie del paziente quindi non
dirigiamo più la nostra attività verso
il tumore bensì la utilizzi dirigiamo
verso il sistema immunitario utili del
paziente e quando siamo bravi a far
questo e quando abbiamo tutti gli
ingredienti giusti riusciamo a vederlo
ottenere delle risposte cliniche che
sono spettacolari lasciatemelo dire è
che in alcuni tipi di tumori penso al
melanoma cutaneo che è un tumore della
pelle del quale fino a pochissimi anni
fa non avevamo assolutamente nulla da
poter offrire ai nostri pazienti
oggi abbiamo più che triplicato la
sopravvivenza di questi pazienti
a dieci anni dal dall'inizio che li
della terapia
quindi stiamo ottenendo dei risultati
estremamente importanti che in alcuni
tumori sono andati oltre la
chemioterapia ad esempio il melanoma ma
certamente ci sono anche altri tumori
sui quali stiamo lavorando e abbiamo
ottenuto dei risultati importanti che
sono oggi a disposizione di tutti che
sono oggi a disposizione
di tutti gli oncologi non solo fuori
dall'italia ma anche in italia e quindi
abbiamo farmaci che funzionano bene per
cancro del polmone del cancro della
vescica nei tumori testa collo e una
lista che si allunga un po come una
galoppata trionfale quasi ogni settimana
quasi ogni settimana
otteniamo ulteriori informazioni
sull'efficacia di questa strategia
terapeutica quindi un cambio assoluto di
paradigma
c'è però da dire che io sono un
entusiasta perché ho sempre lavorato
nell'ambito delle una terapia dei tumori
sono entusiasta di quello che sta
accadendo oggi
ma c'è da dire che la comunità
scientifica internazionale anche quella
che è stata assolutamente scettica
fino a qualche anno fa fino a pochissimi
anni fa ha preso coscienza che quel
gruppo di visionari qualcosa in testa
che l'aveva aveva diciamo degli elementi
per immaginare che si potessero ottenere
dei risultati importanti
quindi oggi l'immunoterapia viene vista
da tutti anche dagli scettici da quelli
che non ci credevano come una strategia
assolutamente importante nel percorso
terapeutico dei nostri pazienti ed è
inutile dire che molti di quegli
scettici oggi sono diventati degli
esperti ma questo fa parte delle cose
che vi è nella natura delle delle
persone quello che però è assolutamente
importante e guardare al futuro cioè
andare oltre ciò che finalmente siamo
riusciti a ottenere dopo decenni di
insuccessi e questo è assolutamente
possibile perché noi oggi abbiamo le
basi scientifiche le basi cliniche per
comprendere come migliorare la
possibilità migliorare la percentuale di
pazienti che risponde ai trattamenti
terapici perché comunque anche nella
migliore delle ipotesi
noi abbiamo che circa il 50 per cento
dei pazienti non trae beneficio da
questo tipo di trattamento ma gli ultimi
decenni non sono passati invano anche in
questo senso perché noi grazie alla
ricerca siamo riusciti noi comunità
scientifica internazionale a comprendere
i meccanismi intimi che regolano questa
abbiamo visto una danza molto bella
prima in questo caso particolare che
regolano la danza due quella fra il
sistema immunitario il nostro sistema
immunitario quello che dentro tutti noi
e il cancro
questa è una razza che per funzionare
richiede moltissimi elementi richiede
che noi conosciamo più di profondamente
le radici di questa che di interazione e
le radici di questa interazione sono
complesse perché sono da un lato il
tumore con tutte le sue sfaccettature
tutte le sue caratteristiche tutte le
sue diversità e tantissimi meccanismi
che mette in atto per sfuggire al
controllo del sistema immunitario
dall'altro lato che lì però abbiamo le
nostre difese immunitarie che sono in
qualche maniera diversa fra tutti noi
hanno un livello diverso di efficienza
quindi solo se riusciamo a mettere
insieme in maniera ottimale
questi due attori riusciamo che di ad
ottenere che il miglior controllo che li
della malattia ma a questo si aggiunge
complessità su complessità
stiamo imparando che il tumore si
nasconde al sistema immunitario non solo
cambiando le proprie caratteristiche ma
sviluppando una nicchia all'interno di
cui vive il cosiddetto microambiente
tumorale che molte volte utilizza le
nostre stesse difese immunitarie alcuni
tipi di cellule del nostro sistema
immunitario per difendersi dalla
sistema immunitario che abbiamo attivato
in maniera specifica con dei farmaci
quindi c'è molto lavoro da fare c'è
moltissimo lavoro da fare ma abbiamo una
base come dire fantastica di lavoro che
parte non solo dai risultati che abbiamo
già ottenuto ma dalle conoscenze che
continuiamo quindi ad acquisire
giornalmente anche sulla funzionalità
del nostro sistema immunitario e in
quest'ottica mi piace ricordare che
lunedì scorso
questi due signori gimelli son et su
conio hanno ricevuto il premio nobel per
una loro scoperta fondamentale nei media
avrete sentito che avevano storie
toccanti di amici che avevano avuto il
campo niente di tutto questo
loro non erano interessati al canto loro
erano interessati a capire come funziona
che di il nostro sistema immunitario e
ci sono riusciti perché sono riusciti a
comprendere che la funzionalità delle
nostre difese immunitarie tutti i giorni
in questo momento in ciascuno di voi
passa attraverso l'interazione fisica
tra le cellule del sistema immunitario
che si parlano fra di loro per
ottimizzare il controllo di ciò che è
estraneo attraverso delle molecole di
membrana da questa scoperta fondamentale
che ha permesso di capire che esistono
dei circuiti regolatori negativi quindi
che spengono la nostra risposta
immunitaria si sono poi generati dei
farmaci diretti in questo momento
prevalentemente contro due molecole una
si chiama ctla 4 l'altra si chiama pd
uno che sono in grado di spezzare di
bloccare questi segnali negativi quindi
che mantengono e potenziano l'attività
del nostro sistema immunitario che a sua
volta e poi in grado in oltre il 50 per
cento dei pazienti in circa il 50 per
cento dei pazienti
mi dicevo di tenere sotto controllo il
tumore e di eliminarlo e di permettere
ai pazienti di vivere e di vive molto
più a lungo rispetto a quello che ci si
sarebbe potuti immaginare quindi questi
due signori hanno certamente contribuito
in maniera fondamentale ai successi
dell'immunoterapia di oggi ma partendo
che di lavorando sulle radici del
funzionamento che di del nostro sistema
immunitario è un po come parlavo qualche
giorno fa con un con un amico grande
produttore di vino che mi diceva per
fare un grande vino
bisogna conoscere le radici bisogna
sapere il quale terreno affondano le
radici
altrimenti non siete non riesci mai non
potrei mai riuscire che di ad ottenere
un grandissimo vino grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]